valve is having another go at bolstering
their security on Steam by limiting
users who've spent less than five bucks
on the platform Valve's hope is to
reduce cases of spam and phishing since
as they explain many malicious users
operate using accounts that haven't
spent any money so as to reduce their
individual risk with this new policy
users who spent less than five dollars
on the steam store will be restricted
from sending friend invite opening group
chats voting on steam greenlight steam
reviews and workshop items participating
in the steam market posting frequently
in discussions gaining steam profile
levels and trading cards submitting
contents to Steam Workshop accessing the
steam Web API and using the browser and
mobile chat so pretty much everything
that isn't straight up buying games and
playing them recently seemed introduced
a two-step mobile authentication into
beta to try and make sure all your steam
things stay yours let me know down in
the comments if you're a fan of this new
steam policy and why or why not stay
tuned to gamespot will we'll keep you
updated on all the latest things steam
and valve